the 12.9 inch ipad pro is by far the
best tablet ever made
every time i pick it up and use it as
cheesy as it sounds
it gives me a bit of joy because of how
amazing the hardware is
but after a month of use and the new
ipad os 15.
if i'm completely honest with myself i
wish that it didn't buy it
and if i could return it i would with
that
even though i love it i'm probably gonna
sell it and i'll explain exactly why in
just a bit
now i can already imagine the haters
commenting on this review
but before you guys come at me i ask you
to take a step back
watch the whole video and pay attention
to the five key points that i have
and i think that most of you guys will
completely agree with me
that this new ipad has some inexcusable
issues that you
absolutely have to know about before you
upgrade or you buy one
i've always purchased the smaller 11
inch pro but this is the first year that
i have bought the 12.9 inch ipad pro for
personal use
mostly because of the new mini led
display and man
is this an amazing piece of tech it
feels even thinner at this larger size
but packs an insane hardware punch and
that's without even considering the m1
chip
or the new hdr display or even the 5g
data connectivity which
no mac has actually this is not only the
best tablet ever made
but possibly the best mobile computing
device ever made
let me cover what i absolutely love
about it before getting into the issues
after using it for a day or two for
basic tasks i had the intention to ditch
my 13-inch m1 macbook
and make this my daily driver combined
with the expensive but really high
quality magic keyboard
the laptop experience was almost perfect
the more roomy keyboard layout is
noticeable with the 12.9 inch model and
i had no problem spending hours typing
and using the trackpad
instead of using my macbook in fact the
experience was overall better because of
three things
first off the display it genuinely feels
expansive when you use it almost like
going from a 13 inch to a 15 inch laptop
now that might sound crazy but the
ipad's 12.9 inch screen
is actually slightly larger than a
macbook's 13.3 inch screen
because of the 4x3 aspect ratio and then
you factor in how much closer you
generally have it to yourself
even with the keyboard because it floats
above it and slightly closer
and then add that the display has top
line reflectivity coatings and it's
rated at 1 600 nits in sdr mode
compared to 400 nits on the macbook air
and this thing is much easier to use in
bright rooms or outdoors
along with that because it's a touch
screen i naturally use both the trackpad
and the display
whichever is faster and more convenient
for the task
and of course if you want to use what is
arguably the best stylus on the market
for
a wide variety of tasks it's right there
and the experience is great with almost
no delay thanks to the 120hz display
now i've always wanted face id in a
macbook because of how quick and easy it
is to log in and authenticate passwords
and purchases
well it doesn't look like apple's gonna
add it to the macbook but it is right
there built into the ipad pro
and makes it just so nice to use with
that
this new ultroid camera and center stage
software makes it really flexible for
web conferencing either by yourself or
the few people
and in terms of microphones this thing
packs five of them and the sound quality
is shockingly good
even in a room with constant hvac noise
and then
let's get to the speakers how in the
world did apple pack
four speakers in this ultra thin chassis
that sound better and louder than a
13-inch
macbook pro and absolutely smoke all
windows laptops that i've heard
just go ahead and take a listen for
[Applause]
yourself
bring me back
[Music]
because of these speakers and the new
display as you can imagine
watching movies is fantastic on the ipad
now yes the aspect ratio isn't the best
but i would definitely take
this to watch a movie compared to my
macbook
the new mini led display looks fantastic
with hdr content
yes there is some blooming but if i had
to choose between an lcd on the 11 inch
or samsung's oled in their best tablet
i would absolutely choose this display
in normally lit rooms contrast levels
look perfectly black just like
oled actually quite a bit better than
samsung's oled display because the s7
plus
has really reflective glass which makes
blacks look great
and erases the main benefit of oled and
then you have the downsides of oled such
as
flicker and that it can't get super
bright maxing out at about 400 nits full
screen brightness
compared to 625 nits for the ipad and
sdr
or up to a thousand for full screen hdr
brightness
and of course that crazy peak rating of
1600 nits
which although almost no hdr movies go
that high
it is just clear how much more pop you
get from the mili led screen
compared to samsung's best oled tablet
comparing it to the 11 inch which uses
the same display tech as a previous 12.9
inch
in daylight viewing content has more
detailed and deeper shadows
as well as much brighter highlights now
will you notice a difference without
putting them side by side like i did
well yes you definitely will if you
upgrade but as i mentioned
most content doesn't take full advantage
of this display
now in darker environments is where the
difference is much more noticeable
hdr content looks just as good as my
high-end lg oled tv
but highlights pop even more and in most
scenes blacks look
pure black compared to gray on the lcd
in general the display is the best of
the best pretty much matching up with my
six thousand dollar pro display xdr
at least in short term hardware
capabilities and this is in a tablet
that starts at a thousand and ninety
nine dollars
now sure there are downsides the same
ones that my 6k display has
if you're in a really dark room and have
the brightness up and viewing bright
white content on a pure black background
you can see blooming now apple gets
around this by using gray in their dark
mode and gray borders around their
white ui and the apple tv app but it is
very noticeable in other apps like
youtube
you can also notice it when watching
things like fireworks or other content
with
really small bright spots but most of
the time this isn't an issue and in
daylight viewing this has never been
an issue it's a shame that apple did
something that i didn't expect
and that's on purpose limiting how you
can use this hardware
which really starts to tick me off every
time i start thinking about it
when i first saw the display and what
it's capable of like many others
my thoughts were to use it as an
additional display for my mac for hdr
editing
you have an ipad on the go and then you
can pair with your mac as the cheapest
way to get a 1 000
hdr image for video editing but apple is
limiting side card to sdr only
even if you connect it through a
thunderbolt cable that is clearly
capable of passing through
enough data since it is used for full 6k
10 bit hdr on their pro display xdr
as soon as you connect it it is limited
to good old
sdr just like the old ipad and the only
reason i could think of that they
wouldn't want you to do this
is likely just for people to do exactly
what i wanted to do
which is not you have my 6k display
which is very expensive
and just be able to use this display for
those times where i really need to grade
hdr footage
but don't worry if you want to use this
display to its full potential
like for example hdr editing yes you can
do that as long as you're using
imovie i have to say that i completely
agree with linus
since apple spends nearly 20 billion
dollars a year on r d which is insane
if their flagship tablet clearly lacks
features especially softer ones it's
because they don't want them to have
them
and now it's time to get into the rest
of the negatives that literally make
this product
almost useless for me personally and
even though it might still work great
for you
we need to push apple to allow it to do
more because the hardware is insanely
good
and the only problems that it has is
because apple
wants it to be that way when apple
showed tim cook sneaking into their own
building to transplant the m1 chip into
the ipad
everybody was absolutely shocked apple
went from showing a chip for just a few
seconds a few years ago
to spending so much time on it with
awesome animations
and action scenes the way they marketed
the m1 chip and its capabilities on
stage
made most of us take this as a sign the
apple finally wants the ipad pro to be a
pro
device now i know that some of you will
say that it already is depending on what
you do
and yes you're right while others will
say that it was never meant to be laptop
replacement some even going as far as
saying
is perfectly fine and actually expected
to spend two thousand dollars on an ipad
and then also buying a macbook and
clearly apple wants you to do just that
along with also an imac
for your home as they showed off a wwe
dc
with software that is straight up
mind-blowing magic
while at the same time not even giving
us a way to format a hard drive
in the files app but hey at least we
finally get a status bar on our tablet
that costs over two grand on one end we
have some of the best software in the
world
and on the other hand we have a
thunderbolt port the apple marketed like
crazy
that can't even connect to many of my
thunderbolt hard drives
they just don't show up because it's not
the exact format that ipad os
needs whereas android was doing this
back in 2014
and even with ipad os 15 10 gigabit per
second drive still connect
over 5 gigabit per second for some
reason there's also no eject button to
properly eject a hard drive
and even though i make sure that all the
apps that access external drives are
closed
i still occasionally get errors on my 4
terabyte ssd
and then they won't mount unless i run
error correction
which of course you also can't do on an
ipad so you need to have a mac
even though ipads have supported usb
type c drives since 2018. apple is
showing off the ipad
being able to connect to external
displays even their six thousand dollar
one
but not really telling you that they
limited the usability so much so
that it is almost useless now on the
ipad
itself they create a software that can
instantly resize
any app to work side by side and adjust
and it can even float around
where you want it but if you connect it
to an external screen
not only can it not expand the usable
space but it limits it to mirroring the
exact content
on the display and it somehow can't even
use the full
16x9 screen oh yeah i guess i know
apple doesn't want it to review that
even though it could easily resize
anything on the ipad they don't want you
to do that now almost every reviewer
that got an m1 ipad early said the same
exact thing
the hardware is incredible and now we
just have to wait a few weeks for ipados
15 to finally take full advantage of it
but as many of you know ipad os 15 was
one of the most disappointing software
updates we've ever had for the ipad
and unfortunately for those of you and
me
that ordered an ipad at launch your
return date ended
on friday two days before the release of
ipad os 15.
sure it is great that the ipad can
finally rotate iphone apps
and yay we can finally put widgets
wherever we want to
how wonderful but what about allowing
apps like procreate or lightroom to use
more than five gigs of ram to increase
their performance
since the m1 starts with eight gigabytes
of ram and it can go all the way up to
16 gigs
just like the m1 max nope we still have
that 5 gig limit
with ipad os 15. what's even more crazy
is that in an m1 mac that can actually
take advantage of 16 gigs of ram
you have the choice to not pay 200 for
it
if you don't need it but you still want
extra storage but guess what
with an m1 ipad pro apple forces you to
get 16 gigs of ram in this year's model
if you want one terabyte of storage and
no
it is not free the one terabyte
configuration costs 300
more this year compared to last year now
a hundred dollars of that
is for the mini led display which is
fair but the other 200
is for that 16 gigabytes of ram which
will literally make
no difference unless you open 25 apps 20
browser tabs with background videos
two high-end games multiple photo and
video editing apps and you export
professional 4k
video and 42 megapixel edited raw photos
at the same exact
time and if you do all of that
you will then see a difference and you
will save a whole
12 seconds on exporting both those
at the same time and then after you do
that at the same time
if you go back through your apps one of
those games will have to
reload on the 8 gig model so with the 16
gig
you'll save about 2-3 seconds of
reloading that app
now sure the m1 chip is an absolute
beast that nothing else can touch
and it destroys every other tablet on
the market even ones that will come out
in the
future but why is cm settings 300 tablet
much more flexible and capable in its
software
than the ipad pro now i'm not asking
apple to make an ipad with macos
even though i know a lot of people would
love that i'm asking them to stop
showing off the massive performance of
this ipad while blatantly
limiting the software so there's no way
they can use it as your main mobile pro
device
even though it can cost up to 2 750rs
paired with their keyboard in the past
we thought the apple was limiting the
software
because they didn't want people to buy
ipads that were cheaper than macbooks
but then they started to raise the price
and they gave the ipad pro
usb type c along with dedicated ipad
software
which started to get our hopes up they
then released the most
expensive keyboard accessory for a
tablet which made the ipad
even more expensive than a macbook
making it even more
likely that apple would finally unleash
the ipad pro but they
didn't and we chalked it up to maybe the
older mobile chip
but about a month ago that changed they
raised prices again at least for the
12.9 inch model and put the same
n1 chip that is in five different macs
and
the same ram and the same ssd so there
were
no more hardware excuses this thing
could
easily run full mac os if apple wanted
to
but now we know apple's true colors if
apple wanted the ipad pro to be a pro
device
it would be but they don't and now i
don't think they ever will because if
there was ever a time
to finally fix these artificial software
limitations
and release pro apps for it now would be
the best time to market that
alongside with the m1 heck even if they
just wanted to limit that software to
the m1 powered ipad pros going forward
that would get a ton of people to buy
them or upgrade and most people wouldn't
complain since the ipad could outrun
even gaming laptops even in software
like beta premiere pro
which is not yet fully optimized but now
there are no more excuses and
any small software fixes that they do
decide to make
will take another year when we get ipad
os
16 at the next wwdc now for me
the l1 ipad pro is unfortunately still
just a high-end tablet like it was
years ago when it was noticeably cheaper
now sure it does have more performance
than before
but for the capabilities that it has i
have never complained that it was
too slow with the older a12z or even
a12x in 2018 and even though now it does
have thunderbolt transfer speeds are
still
much lower than with the mac and
compatibility is extremely limited
the ipad pro is still just a fancy
tablet but just more expensive this time
and apple is doing everything they can
to keep you using both an ipad
and a macbook and after weeks of hauling
both of them in my bag
where this ipad actually weighs more
than my macbook
i'm using it less and less and i'm
mainly just using it for tablet
tasks and if i have to use both as i do
the 11 inch makes much more sense and at
that point the 2018 model is
almost as capable as the new m1 ipad pro
apple could have made this the ultimate
computing device
a full-on computer replacement like in
there
what's a computer ad a few years ago but
instead
they made that video private and instead
decided that
if they can get you to buy an ipad a
macbook
and an imac that is the best thing to
do now sure the m1 ipad is the best
tablet
ever as i explained at the start of my
video it has
insane potential but at this time it is
still
a tablet albeit a very very
expensive one thank you guys for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
you can click that circle to above to
subscribe
that would help us reach our goal of a
million subscribers before the end of
the year
we are really trying hard and hopefully
you guys like the honest content
click that video over there if you want
to check out another one that's been max
and i'll see you
in the next video